on march 11 2011 the fourth most
powerful earthquake in modern history
struck off the coast of eastern japan
powerful waves up to 40 meters in height
inundated coastlines and washed away
entire towns
this left the fukushima daiichi nuclear
power station
75 kilometers from the epicenter under a
dire threat the earthquake cut
electrical lines to the plant
and the tsunami flooded emergency
generators
without power to pump cooling water over
the nuclear fuel
three reactor cores melted down
gases generated from overheated fuel
exploded
and blew apart three buildings
the accident resulted in the greatest
release of radioactivity in the
environment
since the chernobyl nuclear disaster of
1986
10 years since the disaster at fukushima
cleanup at the power plant
is in its early days for one
different damage to each unit required
unique
structures to enable fuel retrieval the
structures for units 2
3 and 4 have been completed
a temporary protective enclosure
surrounds unit 1 while
engineers study how to safely remove the
fuel
major hurdles remain including figuring
out what to do with the water used to
cool melted
and re-solidified fuel debris over a
thousand massive tanks packed throughout
the campus
contain over 1.24 million tons of water
contaminated with radioactivity
a water treatment system removes
radionuclides
and reduces radioactivity
still traces of some isotopes persist
like tritium an isotope of hydrogen
tritium has a minimal impact on human
health unless ingested
and small amounts are naturally present
in seawater
and the atmosphere japan's ministry of
economy trade and industry has proposed
slowly releasing the water into the
ocean and air
but environmental groups the fishing
industry
and neighboring nations condemn this
approach
it's uncertain exactly how the discharge
of the water would impact marine life
but there are concerns about other
radioactive isotopes
of ruthenium cobalt and strontium
accumulating in fish
a solution needs to be found soon as
water storage
will likely run out in 2022
melted fuel debris has yet to be
extracted from any of the units
[Music]
but workers will try to retrieve samples
of the debris using
a remotely operated mechanical arm in
2022
as the cleanup progresses another aspect
of the nuclear accident has emerged
how the disaster impacted evacuees while
the accident was in progress
those living within 20 kilometers of the
plant
and in some adjacent highly contaminated
areas
were evacuated some places have reopened
for habitation
but about 37 000 people are still unable
to return home
uprooting thousands of people had
serious consequences for human health
among 715 residents evacuated from five
minamisoma nursing homes
the risk of death was 2.7 times higher
than before the disaster
there has also been an increase in the
lag between when women recognize
possible breast cancer symptoms
and when they see a doctor making
treatment more difficult
researchers say that better preparing
receiving facilities in the future
could help alleviate the stresses of
displacement
the lessons learned studying the
challenges of decommissioning the
fukushima daiichi power plant
and evacuation could lead to improved
responses
to future disasters
[Music]
you